libsufticktalk.com you guys know libs of
tick tock right they're on um twitter
they're on they're everywhere but i know
them from twitter and what they
essentially do is they post
they're right you know conservative
they post
what people are actually saying what
liberals are actually saying so they'll
post you know images from liberals who
post on tick tock and say things about
what they're teaching in kids schools
and how they don't care about you know
oh i'm doing this even though the
parents wouldn't like it hahaha they
post those videos they post flyers from
actual events
they're showcasing you what these
individuals are actually showcasing of
themselves it's real people just talking
they're just saying here
anyway
leaked internal messages show twitter
employees we're debating whether to ban
lives of tick tock we have a column here
this is from libsubtiftalk.com
i'm going to scroll through to the part
it's a slack conversation that happened
between twitter employees um it was
shared with libs of tiktok by a twitter
employee who wanted to remain anonymous
and they they went through the process
of verifying the names this all happened
on monday
and if you scroll down there's a part
where they say
but if we de-platform this is a
conversation but if we de-platform this
account we might erode trust in our
platform from users who already think
we're irredeemably biased against
conservatives we don't think we know we
see it
we see the bias we see the censorship
it's not a think we know
someone else chimes in on the chat and
says i mean we successfully de-platform
trump i don't think
libs of tick-tock is going to cause a
mass exodus but i guess it may not be in
our fiduciary interest financially they
mean to enact a ban on a high-profile
account right now so this goes on and on
whole conversation about whether or not
they should
shut down lives of tick tock
why
the libs of tick tock is not a site
where
they're going on and they're distorting
someone else's content when i tell you
they are pulling
content verbatim say you're a liberal
you're a teacher
you believe that you know gender
ideology should be taught in preschool
you do it
you want to you know you have pride
flags all over your classroom and you're
you're on tick-tock and you're voicing
how you feel they pull that clip and
they showcase it
that's not distortion
you have an event you make up a flyer
drag drag for kids
whatever it says they post it
they are just
showcasing what you're displaying but of
course twitter has a problem with that
because these people are being exposed
as wanting to indoctrinate children on
tick tock and limbs of tick-tock is just
saying here
this is what they're doing and that's so
incredibly dangerous because twitter
says well this is not a becoming look
once again for our movement for our
cause we gotta shut it down
instead of saying the reaction should be
wow there's a lot of crazy people out
there in classrooms
wow these people shouldn't be teaching
kids wow that's nuts
hmm
no it's well that's going on and we need
to condone it because woke ideology says
that we must says that we must and i've
been brainwashed so i must too
so let's just ban the people that are
exposing reality it's just reality
they're showcasing reality to you
people in their own words can you
imagine getting banned for showcasing
people why aren't those people banned
then
you ban the person who's showing you
what was banned the original content
then i mean but it's no there's no
common sense here
but there's an agenda of course if you
like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]